[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're back
after a break
uh yes the show continues and boy
podcast continue we considered we
considered no we're considered not no we
didn't consider it we didn't consider we
didn't consider not continuing it uh we
had some fun while uh we were away or
you were away from us and we were away
from you we went away
two different not so exotic exactly
exotic locales not uh not exotic in a
traditional sense like we went to uh
well I wouldn't call him exotic I'm just
saying we did some things we did some
dangerous things we did some dangerous
things and it wasn't until just a second
ago that I realized that the theme I
think the common thread of some of the
things that we did uh over the past few
weeks was calculated risk was danger
really maybe people might say why are
you guys doing that don't do things that
you might die doing
huh uh and I haven't thought about it
until right now that we could have died
there was multiple multiple that's a lie
multiple places to tell that you were
thinking about dying
um
well we also we broke the seal on us uh
going scuba diving together yes went
down
that falls under the category of that
was the least dangerous thing we did by
the way I think really
yeah because when you take into account
the depth that we went to I think maybe
you're right I don't know though but one
thing I do know is that boy we are
outdoorsmen we are outdoorsmen we really
like to go on the into the Great
Outdoors and just have a great great
time
we we met our College friends in
Colorado for year two of outdoor
adventure catching up so whoa let's give
them the update on that and the scuba
diving which which do you want to do
first let's do scuba diving first now
I'm ready what's one thing that happened
that I didn't expect it was just amazing
yeah we're gonna save that if we're
gonna say we got to say that at the
right time and it wasn't even unexpected
it wasn't even scuba diving uh
Chase went with us that's what that's
what you're not what you're talking
about Chase
is our guide so uh yeah you've been
scuba diving with Chase before uh this
is my my first time I've never been home
without him and with Chase and uh Chase
brought his camera set up now let me
also say I brought my camera set up and
aborted I aborted really early on
filming anything because of reasons that
I'll get into and also Chase was there
so I talked with Chase at the end of
last week as we were as we were as I was
heading out
you're right behind me and I stopped and
he stuck his head in my window we had a
little exchange I'm gonna fill you in on
that exchange yeah I was like hey I'm
trying to leave here that exchange was
him saying hey do you want me to give
you all the footage that I took from the
dive and I was like no because that
would require me doing something with
like looking through it and I said Chase
this is what would be really helpful if
you would take like
you know
half a minute of some compelling footage
that just is evidence that the three of
us went on a dive together 30 seconds
that then while people are watching your
biscuits on YouTube they can see it at
whatever Point Jamie says this is the
point when I will show the footage I I
know how this show was made uh anyway
that's what Chase promised me and if he
doesn't deliver
it's the it's the end I'm gonna kill him
I'm gonna kill him
no I I think it'll just be me and him
going scuba diving again
we took a boat out to
um
Anacapa and then we went from Anacapa
over to Santa Cruz Island am I right
about those if you don't if you didn't
know there are some there's something
called the Channel Islands I think it's
a national park it is so there is a
string of islands maybe seven or so I've
probably heard of Catalina yeah off the
coast of that's one of them uh
California and at least two of these
islands have been featured as
uh background images for different OS
release Mac OS releases right because
there was a Catalina definitely and I
didn't know there was another one
I'm pretty sure that in one some other
maybe just a background on Mac there was
a Santa Cruz Island picture okay or
something anyway crazy first of all you
know I love Islands crazy history on
these islands and obviously some tragic
history of like the people who lived out
there
um there's like 5 000 people who lived
on the islands where the Spaniards
showed up and then they took them off
the island and made them build churches
and you know ravaged the population uh
there's nobody out there anymore except
there's people who live on Catalina
and
there's some people I don't know which
one was the one on the left and which
one was the one on the right as we were
leaving the one with the arch and then
you got a good view of yeah Kappa is
north of Santa Cruz okay so Santa Cruz
is the one that has like some houses on
it there's some people maybe researchers
or something living out there but we're
talking like desolate Rocky
Islands would just Cliffs essentially
yeah like an hour or so boat ride to get
to from Ventura is where we left from
and we don't go on the island you just
kind of the the captain stops the boat
and gives us this orientation and then
yeah for the first time ever we're scuba
diving together there was a point when
we got in there
it was uh me you chase Shepherd Lincoln
was supposed to come but then he got
sick and he did it was just like a head
cold but you can't go scuba diving with
congestion I mean I didn't have any
congestion I didn't I didn't just can't
equalize I didn't equalize properly and
I still had like a
a burst sinus
the not this most recent time pre when I
got my certification
um so I was sad that Lincoln could make
it especially with what happened and he
was pretty bummed out
but yeah we're going down there we're
we're going we're we're swimming around
and there was a certain point I kind of
forgotten that we had not done this
together we've done so many things
together that like it wasn't top of mind
and then when I was under water
doing my thing you saw how good I was at
it and you were like oh I've never done
this with him before no I was um
I I just turned around I was like I'm
gonna look at my buddy we're at scuba
diving for the first time and I'm gonna
take full credit for this you know he's
so big
well I just took a little Joy from
seeing you having fun and you know what
and your son you deserve you deserve the
credit for taking the initiative I enjoy
it so much
so much
um so that you could then
have you like have your own expectations
exceeded and now look at us man and
listen and think about Shepard I mean
we'll talk about how Shepard did that
day but right now Shepard is in Florida
at a camp where he's like scuba diving
you know it's like you know he's going
to come back more certified than either
one of us officially I think so
I got a report today that he's had a on
and off migraine for a couple of days oh
it prevented him from going in the water
yesterday so I don't know if he's in
further certification is in Jeopardy but
he's having a great time you have to be
perfect
I mean it was beautiful we were we were
scuba diving around we were in the kelp
forest it's
it's relaxing well it is relaxing but I
was dealing with let me tell you what I
was dealing with first of all my son was
there which when your 14 year old son is
your dive buddy
because uh you're not my die buddy
you're my best friend you're not my dive
buddy
Chase was your dad my dad buddy
and that's not like something that you
like do a Blood Oath about that can
change at any moment it can change dive
to dive but when my son is there that's
he's my dive buddy and
I'm thinking about his safety the whole
time I'm being a dad you know and
I'm dealing with my own situation with a
new wetsuit that's kind of choking me
right here I'm also totally fine trying
to be choked
try not to get sick because I get
seasick and I had taken a Dramamine as
we go out there and I was I was like
okay I guess I'm gonna be okay like no
issue going out but then like as you're
sitting there in this boat that's
stationary now that you've stopped and
they're telling you to the thing I
didn't anticipate yeah you know
when you see somebody like scuba diving
I actually noticed this and I watched a
commercial and it was there was some guy
in like a tank with something some
animal I can't remember the details
and I remember every single time I've
ever seen somebody scuba diving on
television
you just look like oh they're just
swimming around in the ocean
and it isn't until you do something that
you realize oh there was a lot of time
that it took to just to get that stuff
on to get your thing to get this thing
strapped it's a lot heavier than you
anticipate and yeah it's like an
Instagram versus reality yeah and it
takes
20 30 minutes or so it feels like to get
all this stuff on and secure
and as you're in this boat that's kind
of doing the side thing and you're prone
to sea sickness and you feel like you're
getting choked and you're dealing with
your son who's having a hard time
getting all his stuff yeah you seem you
seem stressed out and
it you get hot when you're trying to we
get all this stuff and you're trying to
remember everything because if you
forget something and then you're in the
water and you didn't turn your air on or
something it's going to be a big big
problem so stress levels can go up heat
levels can go up and then you're bobbing
around and yeah you start so I'm
starting to get a little queasy but the
other thing that was happening is you
know how kids are like it
you know Shepard will get to a place
where you he like couldn't get his glove
on or he couldn't get his his wetsuit
and he just kind of freezes and just
waits for you to grab it and it's like
you kind of feel like you're doing all
the work and he's not like advocating
for himself and so I'm literally saying
things like advocate for yourself
I wasn't even beside you and I heard
that like there's other people in the
boat dude I don't know a lot of other
people yeah yeah well and like we were
Fathers and Sons
of the boat and all of a sudden I hear
for yourself I'm like what yeah you got
to be at you but the reason I guess
Shepherd's not epic the reason I use
that term is because that's the term
that Hal used when we were training yeah
it is important he was like you've
Shepherd you've got to advocate for
yourself throughout this process anytime
he would come to help him and then so it
wasn't like I used that kind of language
my son on a regular basis it was
actually nicer than what I usually would
say
um and way more technical but so he was
having a tough time and then he was
thinking I'm being choked because it's
cold the water's cold it's like 60
degrees which sounds warm but is very
cold for water and
you got like this vest over the top of
it so there's lots of things like
bunching up around these McLaughlin
necks that are causing trouble
and so but we get in we do the dive and
what I noticed is I'm glad I went first
because if I were just listening to this
you're not selling it at the end of the
dive
uh because there was so much current you
know this diving in the uh in the
Caribbean is like going to
an amusement park it's so easy the water
is warm there's no current you're not
wearing anything yeah but like
the kelp forest was moving with us right
because as the waves come
to come up against the island they kind
of move you at the same rate but then
right the background like the bottom of
the ocean rocks and stays stationary and
I looked down and felt this and it
immediately got sick like to the point
of thinking I was gonna vomit in the
water you know you're underwater at this
point underwater yes and I again for my
training
Hal who did a great job training me
Hollywood divers he was like
if you have to vomit do it do it into
the regulator don't take it don't take
it out and just vomit through the
regulator and you're just like ow into
the water and I was like bro I don't
think I'm gonna be able to do that and
the reason why is because when you're
vomiting you have this natural reflex
natural reflex to then like
and then if you're like doing that
without your regulator in water goes in
the pipes yeah you're gonna be and then
if you're sucking down water
you're going you might be in a in a in a
panic situation so we get out and you
did not vomit did not vomit how close do
you feel like you got I mean I have a I
have an issue with vomiting meaning that
it takes so much to actually get me to
even when I want to when I'm so sick and
I'm like if I could just vomit I just
can't do it so I got out of the water
and you get back into this boat that's
like the wind is beginning to pick up
and it's just like still feeling choked
dealing with Shepard who's like I got a
headache
long story short Shepherd had a headache
didn't do the last two Dives and kind of
just laid up on top of the boat he ended
up having a good time it didn't let ruin
scuba diving for him
but I was dealing with the the
queasiness like coming and going the
whole time but everything more dream I
mean and it's still I took a second one
but every time I got in the water I felt
good
it was always at the end of the dive
that would be a little but the last dive
we did three days the last dive was my
favorite dive no sickness at all can I
say something not having to think about
your son and worry about now that you
did Tim you had an awesome time I'm just
going around who I don't they paired me
up with that dude that was from another
group yeah I don't care about that guy
you know I lost him several times
you're a great you're a great buddy but
he also was he didn't want to be found
he didn't he didn't seem like he really
wanted to be a buddy at anybody but red
what you need to remember about what you
just said was that if you needed help
you didn't have you and Chase were okay
yeah you were basically with us
and we didn't talk about this do you
remember this one point where I turned
around and looked at you and I took the
regulator out of my mouth
and sometimes I'll take the regulator
out of my mouth because I'm like I might
swish ocean water around my mouth yeah
I'll do I'll just like that wasn't part
of my training I'm trying to get
comfortable with the regulator being
missing and putting it back in my mouth
yeah and it's important keep my stress
levels lower it makes me feel more
prepared for something to go wrong like
if I do have to hold my breath you
suppose you're not supposed to ever hold
your breath you're supposed to keep your
regulator in I took my regulator out I
wasn't I wasn't about to vomit or
anything I was having a great time
and I turned around and I looked at you
and I took my regulator in my mouth and
I'm like
I I put it towards you I knew that you
were just being being foolish I was just
being foolish but there was this one
moment where which is not a good thing
to do yeah by the way I realized how
dumb that was when you kind of I saw
that you shut it a minute and you were
like
do you want me to give you my I have an
octopus regulator a packet regulator
that I can give you so did you need this
and I was like no I'm fine and I was
like oh yeah I shouldn't no horse play
horse
well it's one thing to horseplay is one
thing to do the thing that you would do
if you were having a crisis as a joke
I'm sorry this is why you're not my
diode and never will be but I didn't do
it to chase though I did it to you
because you're not into my dog to do
anything
I don't even know why I did it I was
just like I'm having a good time hey
look at me it's my regulator my
regulator's out
um but yeah so uh yeah thank you for uh
being there for me I quickly remember
what's going on but we had a great time
we I keep wanting to see something big
sharks included we saw some a lot of
sharks we saw some little sharks
um I want to see these big animals
because there's a thrill in it and I
think that there's actually a very very
low risk of anything happening to you
it's pretty uncommon for a shark to
attack a scuba diver
I don't I'm not basing that on anything
I've read it's just kind of a feeling
okay yeah let's go with that because
this is my theory and tell me if I'm
right or wrong about this you're right
I think you're more likely to be
attacked by a shark while swimming or
surfing because you're kind of on the
surface and you're thrashing and you
more resemble maybe a wounded animal but
when you're down and still highly
unlikely in those scenarios but when you
are down in the water
in this and you've got these bubbles
coming up and you're big and there's
this tank like a shark can figure out
like this is not what I usually eat and
so I'm not gonna eat it now if you're
like holding the fish and you're like
chumming up the water or whatever all
bets are off but that's my theory that's
why I don't have any fear about sharks
in the water
I'm yeah I don't find myself being
afraid of anything
except
I'm not afraid of the animals
um
I'm afraid what am I afraid of
I had to over I talked about overcoming
my fears of like just being underwater
and because I don't like holding my
breath but you don't hold your breath so
like clearing what equalizing now that
I've had an like an a sinus injury I
have a little bit of fear about that and
I think I have a fear
that of the unknown of like something
going wrong and I still I'm not going to
keep my wits about the abyss no of just
uh problem solving and keeping cool I
think I would be the situation I haven't
encountered yet that I think might make
me nervous
is
like you can dive under an oil platform
right and oil platforms go
very deep like way deeper than you can
scuba dive okay and but there's no
bottom to it right every place I've I've
I've Dove dived yeah
which one is it
yeah both this seems like something we
should know
Dove dived Scooby Dove see that sounds
horrible scuba Dove a scuba Dove
no you're Scuba dived
well what once you dive you've Dove it
says both are acceptable see
yeah but in the context of scuba we're
in North America scuba dived I know but
that's you know
so
and Chase wants to do an oil platform
dive
because there's lots in fact I was
watching um
Instagram Tick Tock something I don't
know and they were the guy was like you
know there's people who live and work on
oil platforms and they make Tick Tock
accounts of course because it's an
interesting lifestyle what else are they
gonna do and they said this is I saw one
that was like this is what happens when
you throw
a piece of bread or something off of an
oil platform and he threw it off and
immediately hundreds of little fish went
up to it and started eating it and then
within five seconds a big shark came and
ate a bunch of the fish and so it was
kind of like this is what's happening
under oil platform because stuff falls
off of it stuff grows on the platform
there's a lot of interesting it's a
little ecosystem but there's no bottom
to it the bottom is you say you're
afraid of the Abyss well because you've
got weights on you now I haven't had any
trouble with like regulating my uh by
buoyancy to the point where I would be
really nervous about that and also you I
know where to grab to pull the weights
off so you go back to the surface but I
think that just looking down and seeing
the abyss which I've never seen
I suspect that that's going to be
unsettling
like if I go down there it's lights out
man literally let's find out I mean
let's not talk about the submersible
I don't want to bring that into this
what are you talking about I don't even
know it's good just Jenna have we sold
scuba diving to you I mean are you open
to this you're a bit of a risk taker I
am I am open to scuba diving
even after the way Rhett talks about it
yeah he's such a Debbie Downer I'm
having the time of my life
and you wouldn't know it uh but what
I'll tell you what I did not have the
time of my life doing is being on the
boat but before that return trip
something highly unusual that I don't
think
we have an appreciation for because this
is actually my Norm first ever
trip scuba diving that required boating
to any place
and something happened to us that Hal
said has only happened to him once in 30
years of scuba diving
we saw a Shark weiner
well technically you would see two
because they have two penises but no
that's not what we saw
we they were given an alert that um
there was a sighting and so then they
said we're going to take a little detour
before we do our third dive we're going
to go over here and when we got over to
the spot which was more in the middle of
the ocean not close to any of the
islands
there was another boat there with like a
lot of people spectating on it
and then we saw I'll let you say it
orcas a freaking pot killer whales we
saw just a bunch of killer whales and me
and Shepard they were like you want to
go around the front of the boat I mean
you're on you're you're on the top but
Shepard and I walked around to the front
to like the the bow of the boat
and we're looking over
and we're seeing they're like surfacing
and it's like oh here's two little Shamu
and then a baby well don't say shampoo
not Shams these are very much not Shamu
I wish they I wish it was they don't I
mean these are free Wild no yeah no
bending of the dorsal fin
fully erect dorsal fin and and we see
them and then the boat positions itself
such that these two killer whales go
right in front of the boat and I'm
looking I'm seven feet
above these killer whales like going
right in front of the boat
it was a thrill and then I looked out
there and there were some other ones out
there that were absolutely huge they're
so big and people were scrambling to
like take pictures and photo uh video
and
we don't have any of that to show for it
yeah because I didn't want to miss any
of it and I knew after you know I knew
that I wasn't going to get anything
worth the crap you know what you know
what killer whales look like you can
watch videos of them you don't need to
see ours now it was pretty magical this
is kind of and they were the two in the
front were absolutely gargantuan I
haven't really let this sink in but you
realize this is the exact same spot that
you saw like three blue whales last time
and my only ever whale watching well
look I've got well luck yeah you're the
whale boy and that's why I mean I've
been talking about I've got two ideas
for my next tattoo and one of them is a
big whale skeleton a whale boy but maybe
well maybe I'll do both of them but
yeah I saw blue whales which was highly
unusual there's only like 15 000 of
these things in the world and then
seeing orcas in California is pretty
rare according to these folks who go out
to this area and there was this added
tension
because if you've been following the
news you know that
the orcas in uh I think maybe it's the
Straits of Gibraltar
somewhere over there on the other side
of the world
um they've been organ they've been
organizing yeah and take and attacking
boats and taking the Rudders off of
boats not seeming like they want to kill
the people on it but seeming like they
want to dismantle the boats just to
mobilize the boat and it's become and I
don't know a whole lot about it but
based on like secondhand information
from my wife explaining a Twitter thread
to me
just to contextualize how wrong this
could be
apparently there was one female Orca
that had a run-in with a boat like
with a something that you know damaged
her
and she has a personal Vendetta against
boats and she is spreading the word
about how we gotta we gotta dismantle
these boats and that's what's happening
and if you think that that's impossible
if you think that orcas cannot send that
technical of a message to one another
you are highly likely wrong I think that
what we're going to find out about
according to third hand information I
think what we're going to find out about
whales is going to blow your mind in
terms of how smart they actually are and
the level of communication they have
people are working to to figure that out
right now but our boat didn't have a
Rudder no and so when we were there was
this like is this thing they're trying
to take us out because the boat's not
very big
um but that was when the captain said
our boat doesn't have a Rudder it's got
a motor
and uh yeah so we felt like we might be
okay that was a thrill that was the
thing we were building up to
I'll tell you another thrill that we
need to build up Good Mythical evening
is happening again we just want to throw
a little plug in here uh what's what's
the date of this bad boy
the 24th
Thursday whatever that Thursday is
Thursday August 24th Thursday August
24th at um it's right here 7 P.M Pacific
7 P.M Pacific which is 10 p.m Eastern
live streaming on kids we get your
tickets at Good Mythical evening.com
we're doing things a little bit
different this year uh you have you have
a big big part because we're gonna do is
it's good mythical evening pain versus
pleasure or pain or pleasure and you're
going to be able to vote live in a
number of ways that determine whether or
not we or one of us or both of us
experiences pain or pleasure at
different points throughout the evening
uh so it's all going to be on you the
level of entertainment has nothing to do
with us it's all to do with you and it's
uh you know it's it's still from the GMM
set but entirely new
um not safe for work
segments one right after another just
you know just mounted on top of each
other if you know what I mean and did I
mention that we're still going to be
drunk
yep we're going to be quite inebriated
and subject to your whims
so
there's different types of tickets the
t-shirt is awesome
so like a sort of little you can get
that around a couple of them
um a couple of different ticket packages
and also for the first time ever uh
we're doing a little partnership with
the Alamo Drafthouse like our favorite
music music favorite movie theater you
know where you go and you can like eat
and watch a movie at the same time and
we just love the vibe there and you can
drink there yeah so they'll serve you
beers at select locations around the U.S
you're going to be able to watch Good
Mythical evening there with other
mythical beasts and highly limited those
are going to go out briefly so get those
tickets quickly to have this Good
Mythical evening communal experience at
an Alamo Draft House near you or watch
from the comfort of wherever you want to
watch us just get hammered
um and unfettered but it we're we're
going to be totally safe about it it's
just going to be totally unhinged Good
Mythical evening.com
ear biscuits is brought to you by
betterhelp you know one of the aspects
of adulting is making decisions
figuring out how you're going to
navigate things and you know a lot of us
just kind of stay in our own heads and
try to figure it out there uh I did that
for a very long time and maybe I would
consult with a friend here or there but
therapy was not only transformational in
helping me
approach things from like a you know
access my emotions in new ways but when
it just comes to those decisions about
tough life stuff right having a
qualified wise person to talk through
things sometimes simply saying something
out loud and hearing someone's
perspective on it is enough to
send you in a certain direction and
that's been a really beneficial part of
therapy for me I like what you said
about getting out of your head for me to
like actually talk it out of my head in
in verbally
has been tremendously helpful and hey we
recommend therapy for you if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
better help visit betterhelp.com ear
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
help.com ear earbiscus is supported by
Factor you know uh I'm a busy man you're
so busy I'm married to a busy woman oh
she's so busy we have busy kids they're
so busy everybody has to eat link I
think that what we're after is we're
after convenience
yeah quickness but also like good taste
and health those are the things that
we're after when it comes to our meals I
feel that and I don't like making a
decision because then I revert to just
going through a drive-through let's talk
about Factor America's number one ready
to eat meal kit it can help with your
decisions and your nutritions and your
eatings with ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door so far
I've had
um a few things I had this Chipotle Road
pork chop
very good I had some sun-dried tomato
chicken okay and I was I was just very
kind of I was floored with how it was
literally like I looked at the
instructions it was like
pierce the film heated up heat up for
two minutes now it's not microwave it's
fresh it's never Frozen and the meals
are already eaten just two minutes of
eating and so if you're on the go they
have effortless wholesome meals like
grain bowls and salad Toppers that are
ready to eat when you're on the go no
microwave required and they've got
calorie smart meals and Protein Plus
meals so no more than 550 calories per
serving serving and 30 grams of protein
or more and Factor offsets 100 of their
delivery emissions sources 100 renewable
electricity for production sites and
offices and features sustainably sourced
Seafood in the meals so head to
factormeals.com
ear50 and use code ear 50 to get 50 off
that's a lot of percentage off that's
code ear five zero at factormeals.com
ear five zero to get 50 off
uh to wrap up the scuba trip the scoop
that we scuba does we did no we didn't
because you've got uh photo evidence
that I've seen that's pretty funny of my
trip back so yeah that's right once we
started going did not look good once we
started going back it's I don't think
you we we can uh communicate just how
unexpectedly and suddenly rough the trip
was when we started to take off it was
like boom and you were in the freaking
bathroom at the time I was I was trying
to change clothes
and I was having trouble staying in the
boat here I am naked
trying to pee in the toilet because I
had I had a new wetsuit I didn't pee in
it I just well you had a semi-dry suit
so it's right it's a little bit
different than peeing in a wetsuit
exactly
yeah it was it was tough to uh not vomit
down I gave my yellow offerings when I
came up
and got up top
yeah you were you were quiet you were
received like six times you were staring
off into the distance
and you you didn't look good so I took a
I took a little bit well it's an hour
trip back and it was it didn't let up at
all and here's the thing it wasn't like
I've had miserable seasickness before
like when I when I got in the paper for
catching that 55 pound amberjack when I
was like in ninth grade and that and I
did throw up that day
um it wasn't that I knew I wasn't gonna
vomit but I was like I'm gonna be
uncomfortable until we get back and I'm
just gonna have to sort of sit here and
take it yeah and so I did that I just
sat there and took it and you took a
pretty good picture I didn't I mean it
seemed like it was like uh
like I thought you had like done some
some post work on that picture based on
based on really true I was like that's a
good looking picture I mean I hope
showing it now or yeah I did I never
thought I didn't think anything of it it
was just like I just snapped a cool
picture oh I just snapped a shot I look
like an idiot I just wanted to make sure
that I remember that moment if none
other you know forget the killer whales
I want to get a shot of this this giant
being miserable on a boat yeah I don't
it's funny because I don't get car sick
you get car sick but you don't get
seasick I get seasick I don't get car
sick what's the deal with that
um well you you just giving yourself
permission
you shouldn't do that you think I'm
giving myself so are you giving yourself
permission to get car sick yeah because
that allows me to like sit in the front
seat and be like you know I'm the one I
get car sick can I sit in the front
but is there something physiological
happening that I don't
I don't understand well it's certainly a
different motion
Motion in the ocean yeah it's different
from the motion on the roads and let's
let's skip to the river though because I
want to get to this okay
um highly recommend scuba diving
you may remember that last year we went
white water rafting with our college
buddies who we had reconnected with
um
really through our spirituality
construction episodes we started
reconnecting pandemic hit right on the
heels of that so like we we um we just
really
reconnected over the course of pandemic
we put put that into
physical action of being on a trip
together that was a weird sentence and
uh now it's year two we're getting some
we're getting some college buddy
momentum yeah I mean
and we decided on the first trip we're
going to do this again we need to learn
from you know our whitewater rafting was
kind of boring and I was like ah we're
gonna do something better this time so
like nine months in advance
we started planning and I started
looking at
what's something that's a more exciting
thing
and we settled on doing white water
rafting again because the first time it
was it just was it was just lackluster
we wanted to make it more intense and we
wanted to move it up a little bit in the
year because we learned that most of the
Whitewater reacting that happens in
Colorado is due to the snow melt so if
you wait till you wait till July July
mid-july which we did last time you're
not gonna you're gonna get like little
piddling stuff
also this year crazy snowpack right so
there's just so much snow in the Rockies
so there was lots of talk about how
intense this was going to be and this is
something that once I saw that you were
very like you were just like
I had nothing to do with it I'm gonna
figure this out you were like totally
committed to being like we're gonna
figure out where we're gonna go and this
is not gonna be boring and I was like
okay yeah I'm totally down we didn't
plan enough stuff the first time we were
like
well you know we ended up just riding
scooters around downtown it was lame
well we did some good stuff I disagree
with your assessment I know I know you
did complain about we were having a
great day that one day on those bikes
that everyone was talking about how fun
of a time they were having how beautiful
this town of gold in Colorado was and
you just kept talking about all the
things you didn't like about what's
happening well that's because I learned
it from you and how you talk about scuba
oh come on I know in the moment I don't
say a damn thing I only talk about it on
the podcast uh I was I was [__] talking
to scootering not the e-biking okay
um so I'm like Googling the most
exciting white water rafting and then
yeah I might have put it in the term
extreme
and I might have put in the term like
class fives and class fours I don't want
no class threes or class twos anymore
and we have done classifies before we
maybe 20 years ago in the upper golly in
West Virginia prepared you know we can
do this and Greg was with us then but
once you got the trip set up where I
where my anxiety began to brew a little
bit and I typically don't get I don't
get scared about doing things I get uh
sort of properly concerned but I'm not
like scared I'm just kind of like is
this dumb
and when I asked that question
it was because
I've been white water rafting quite a
bit but never have they asked us to show
up a day early
to do a test
I mean I've been on the upper golly they
didn't ask us to do a swim test and they
were like you got to come uh the day
before
we're gonna put you in the boat we're
going to do a swim test we're going to
take you down a rapid it's planned for
two hours
you're going what meaning you're gonna
you're gonna pre-raft intentionally jump
out of the raft
and then swim
and they want to purify that you can say
you could do it that you can pull each
other back into the boat because
obviously if you fall out you want to
get back into the boat
so it's an assessment so they can say
yeah you guys are not ready
this was in Durango Colorado
um in the Animas River uh upper animus
and the upper animus it was just like
there was a trip that was class fives
and class fours and I was like yes this
is what we're gonna do and and then it
was you do a day of rafting and then you
camp on the side of the river and then
you get up the next morning and you keep
going on class fours and class threes
the rest of the way
and I was like yes this we may be
swinging the pendulum too far the other
direction but we're not going to be
saying that we didn't get a thrill out
of this trip and I felt good about that
everybody else had a lot of questions
especially when they started scheduling
the swim test well like you said and
everybody was a little bit
I don't know I didn't want to camp I
mean just be honest I I've got a bad
back uh that I actually keep
pretty ready for anything but what can
happen is if I have a bad night's sleep
I can wake up and it can feel really bad
and the idea of camping yeah in a tent
and then getting up and going on this
River after having been on the river
yeah I was a little bit like I'm not
gonna be I'm not gonna be uh what do you
what is it called when they bring a
helicopter to get you airlifted yeah I'm
I'm gonna be airlifted because of a
lower back injury well because the the
terrain was such that
they you we went to a train station
and we loaded like the deflated rafts
and everything and well we had guides
who did all of this and we just watched
and we're like yeah let's go for it they
definitely did and then we get on this
train and we ride up this train track
Into the Wilderness into the middle of
nowhere there's no accessibility except
for the train track there's no roads
there's nothing so you're exactly right
you would have to be trained pulled out
or airlifted out if it's beyond the
train track which a good part of it was
I think it would have been a chopper
situation
um so I think that's why they want to
make sure if you're hey if we're taking
these chumps out into the Wilderness we
got to make sure that they can get us
back down this down this River
um
so we were you know I every time we
would talk about it in the thread
I I felt like I would have to say now
people would raise concerns and I'd be
like but we're but now when I'm backing
out we're still doing it everybody was
still doing it but we were still doing I
was watching the the flow rate of the
river because in doing a little bit of
reading
I was like
wow when this river flows Above This
certain number
it can be dangerous people have died and
it was flowing at that rate and it was
going a little bit above it and a little
bit below it in like the weeks leading
up and so I was just like I'm still
gonna do this I'm not gonna back out and
I don't think anybody in our group is
going to pull the cord yeah
um and nobody did but there was mounting
concern about the conditions and also
the camping situation yeah I I was
mostly concerned about
two days you know and overnight yeah
but I wouldn't back it out either
because I was talking big
and then
balls to the wall four days or so before
we leave
um we get the news that our trip has
been canceled completely
um the rafting part the the rafting
company has canceled our trip
and the tragic reality is that a guide
died on the river
um so you know our hearts go out to so
to to the family and all the people you
know um but the and then we were like
okay so now what do we do well there's
um there's one other company in town
we'll rebook with them
well we're like all right let's let's
slow our this is this is a good
opportunity to like assess
maybe we should take a beat and think
about this so uh we went with
uh we were Mild to Wild we we appreciate
the responsibility they took in saying
you know what is best if we cancel this
trip so we took a beat and we said all
right we're gonna call up Mountain
Waters rafting yeah and take their
suggestion which was let's let's let's
forget the let's forget the overnight
camping I also don't think that they had
that option I think fate helped this
decision be made it was like yeah
there's a trip that is the lower half of
the upper animus so the part that just a
one day no over after the camping would
have happened and we're like one class
four to start so yeah let's do that
let's do that so we booked that and
um
I feel like that was a great choice you
know I because we had an Airbnb why not
stay in that instead of like camp on the
ground and do two full days of this
thing so we get out there uh Mountain
Waters shout out to you guys did an
awesome job we hadn't we we had an
amazing time but we get out there
and of course we had done the swim test
with them still for the lower half of
the upper animus the night before the
day before and boy that water is cold
and that water was not half as cold as
it was up there when we started because
everybody was 38 degrees Yeah he said
every single drop of water that we will
be rafting in today was snow yesterday
yeah and we were wearing wetsuits but uh
we were wearing wetsuits with like
another jacket over it
38 degrees like it's so bracingly cold
you don't really want to fall in and
when it just splashes up in like one
drop hits your face it's yeah and it's
and more than one drop hits your face
like every it was so intense
so consistently intense and white water
the whole way because the thing drops so
much yeah that you are getting wet
the entire time you don't have a lot of
time to think about how cold you are
though no because
from the moment we put in the moment we
got out like you said just constant
waves of white water no reprieve yeah
and I was in the front of the boat with
Greg and two other people and then you
Tim and harm were in the another boat
because they had to split us up and um
so I enjoyed watching you guys go down
and like I mean it was like riding a
buck and Bronco yeah I mean and there
would be these huge like waves that
would just be churning and we would just
nose first boom into these things just
hitting walls of river waves that just
splashy in the face and
try to knock you out of the boat
and it was relentless and absolutely
amazing and Scenic too because it's
complete Wilderness you don't see you
don't see anybody driving a car in a
road by you you might see a train the
train go by I don't remember even seeing
the train going by it might have but we
ain't gonna stop and look at a train I'm
looking at this train it was it was
exactly the level that I was hoping and
I didn't ever feel like my life was in
danger
the only thing I felt because the very
first rapid was the class four was the
most intense yeah talk about a start
um
the very first time we went up on this
wave and then came down and the boat
kind of like slaps down and you kind of
collapse
that's when I start thinking
how am I going to do this without
hurting my back right because you're
you're supposed to tell them if you've
got back problems I never do you know
what are they gonna do when it comes to
roller coasters whitewater rafting Etc I
don't have back problems okay when it
comes to my actual reality I do but I
don't come to this podcast you certainly
do but I don't want to be limited from
it oh come on roll your eyes dude if you
if how you know how much I would hear
about it if you had the back issues that
I have man was my shoulders you know oh
yeah your shoulder okay so the every
time we s we would go like this it would
be like a little twinge compression and
I would be like okay I got to figure
that was the only thing I was thinking
is like I don't want to get hurt and be
compromised for the rest of the rest of
this day yeah
um and not be able to like paddle right
but once we got through that and I was
like okay I think I'm gonna be okay I
had a blast the rest of the time I wish
I could go back to the class four
knowing that I was gonna be okay and I
would have enjoyed it a little bit more
I had a point like halfway a little over
halfway in the trip
where
I was a little disappointed in myself
because we're going through these Rapids
and then it's because it's constant I
just found myself thinking like
what are we gonna do for dinner
what are we gonna do after dinner well
it's hard to not want something that's
really fun but a little bit
uncomfortable to be over
we'll be thinking about that that was I
mean because we were cold that was part
of it
but just my mind wandering I'm sitting
here like
paddling my ass off
and I'm not my mind's not there like I
was disappointed in myself it's like man
this is exactly what you had hoped for
it's it's going
it it's it's me it's exceeding all your
expectations yet you're sitting here
thinking about it to be present you're
saying about a sandwich it's hard to be
present you know because it's just it
was it was
you kind of lull you into this place of
like like rocking a baby to sleep almost
well I wasn't about to go to sleep in a
in a tempest
you know it's like a baby sleeping in a
tempest that that's where I was
I just kind of you know maybe it wasn't
quite enough for me
I I nobody fell out maybe I needed to
fall out dude I just feel like well it
just we didn't it didn't quite
go extreme enough so this is what I
wanted me to be jolted into like into my
body I need to be jolted and say hey
you're you're mortal
this is what I wanted to talk about uh
because the extreme choices did not end
with the whitewater rafting right the
next day
we got on these side by side utvs yeah I
was like let's do some let's do some
agents which uh I had never been on
before always wanted to so again these
are like the dune buggies where you're
like two seats side by side
um essentially you're there's a role to
it there's a roll cage so that if you
fly off it's not a four-wheeler you know
and and I booked this I well I asked
Kara to book this and I said I want to
do ATV and I don't want to guide
yeah yeah that was a good call because
because the guide you got to stay behind
the guide
and you got to go where the God goes and
you got to go to the speed
of the guy and the guide says things
like well not just the guide but the
guys who
oriented us to this we're like don't do
any drifting around the turns and all
this stuff and like watch yourself
around blind curves
because we're gonna the route was to go
up this mountain this was uh Purgatory
ski resort which in summer is just a
beautiful
um Mountainside where you can go
mountain biking you can go Alpine
roller coaster riding yeah and you can
ATV around those things it's absolutely
beautiful in there and
a little bit just a little bit of snow
at the top yeah which we made it all the
like the whole the route was to go all
the way to where the snow was and we we
went beyond where we were supposed to go
because we had gone pretty fast we had
three so um ATVs utvs so I was like I'll
I'll go by myself for the first part I
found that an interesting choice because
the way that you presented it in the
moment was that is as you were making
some kind of sacrifice to go by yourself
and I was like well of course everyone
wants to go by their cells first it's
funny that was ah I'll go by myself and
drive first what hold on really no I I
honestly think that's how you see it I
think you must have seen it differently
when I was like everyone I didn't think
anybody would want to be by themselves
but hold on there's Five Guys there's
three steering wheels so by saying I'll
go by myself first you're guaranteeing
that you get to drive first of course
nobody wants to be the passenger first
so so yeah I didn't think of it so well
clearly you didn't think of it that way
when you said I was like okay link
um so because I want to be with people I
thought I was taking one for the team
that was I was clearing the way you
presented and by the way but you also
wanted to drive because I drove first
I drove on the more boring part when we
started switching up so I actually did
take one for the team
okay I'm that's your perspective that's
fine
um what I'm saying is that is what I'm
saying is that when we I was like okay
who's gonna go Who's Gonna Be by
themselves first because that person's
probably going to end up driving more
and they're gonna get to drive from the
beginning I didn't drive more we all we
ended up working out the math we ended
up working on the math so that it was
even
um and I also drove first with
Greg no Tim Tim is my uh passenger we
all switched it up so that everybody
would be with everybody else the one
thing that I said from the top is like
I'm not going to be a passenger while
link is driving I didn't hear you say
that I told everybody else oh I just
said my only rule is I'm not going to be
a passenger while he's driving huh
um which proved to be
uh what is the word
prophetic uh what
so
you don't have a perception of how you
are man like you you like you've lost
you've lost your own plot when it comes
to this kind of I am Immortal
risk-taking thing so I mean again like
breaking your pelvis balls to the wall
breaking your shoulder balls to the wall
like there's evidence of of you my back
feels great of you not calculating your
own risk and so but what ended up
happening we're going first of all we're
going very fast these things probably go
55 top speed we're getting above 50.
I'm not listening to the what the guy
told me I'm doing fishtailing and and
stuff all around the these curves it's
like the most fun thing yeah you were
and you were in front of me
yes and um I saw you do that and I was
like good idea it was so fun I didn't
even and it was a big wide road and
these are giant like fire roads like
it's like there's no there's very little
risk in it
there in there becomes this place where
we transitioned to we had switched
actually twice by that point but we got
to a place where it became more of a
trail and now we're in a mountain pass
on this Trail and the trail is you know
it's not it's no longer like a
well-couched road it's wet it's got
giant potholes it's got a giant drop off
on the side of the mountain all the way
around because it's like the Switchback
going up the mountain and at this point
I'm driving by myself
you're driving and Greg is your
passenger and I'm behind you and then
harm and Timber behind me
yeah so at some point like the thing
that's so amazing about these utvs is
they're so forgiving the shocks are
incredible I'm like why don't they make
shots on cars like this we could do
anything we if you put shocks on cars
like we need we need payments people
would just be driving over mediums it's
like you can go like 50 miles an hour
and hit a median it's like no big deal
it's crazy the way these things forgive
what was that nothing
but what I was noticing was I was like
going around some of these turns like
there's a bunch of blind turns and by
the way there's other people out there
on vehicles uh you know you come around
these turns and you can't see anything
blind turns and also every once in a
while you come to like a big rock or a
big dip or something and it would like
really jar you but when you're driving
like you're holding onto the wheel and
you kind of anticipate it
I was behind you and I was going as fast
as like I was going a little bit faster
than I was comfortable and felt was safe
I was like I'm taking this is a little
too risky I'm probably going too fast
I could not catch up with you and Greg
and so I thought to myself I was like I
can only imagine what Greg is going
through right now because as a passenger
you don't have any control you just have
to kind of like just close your eyes so
we get to the next part where we switch
and this is where Greg is going to come
drive and I'm going to be the passenger
as we go down yeah Greg Greg who's quiet
and didn't say anything to you Greg was
like
I don't know if I can drive my nerves
are shot
really
he said oh he said poor Greg link is a
Madman and I was like well what did I
tell you at the beginning of this I'm
not going to be a passenger while he's
driving
because he doesn't have any he was like
he went around every blind curve
completely pedal to the metal never
slowed down he went around every blind
curve didn't slow down at all and he
said he would come to these big rocks
and stuff like you know there was a
couple places where like the the rock
kind of coming down the side of the
mountain become the trail completely
just a rock there's no traction on that
and he was like he just would he didn't
slow down on any of the Rocks he didn't
slow down
at any moment
and I was like yes that's why I said I
wasn't going to ride with him well you
know
so it's interesting to me that you don't
have a perception that maybe what Greg
was experiencing was pure Terror the
entire time well let me give my
perspective
okay
uh first of all the faster you go the
less you feel the bumps
fact
um and yes
I did notice that uh
uh there was a pool of urine forming
around Greg's seat
I didn't notice in many points
that Greg would eke out a sound yeah
right and it was kind of like
ah it was kind of like that
I mean every every time he would go
I would go
Mario
[Laughter]
just having the time of our lives
because uh I was it's tough to be like
it's first of all as a passenger it's
tough because you're not in control
so
like I didn't feel like I was taking
some of those turns and I was like I'm
right on the edge of my comfort zone
and I really hope there's not somebody
coming around
but the whole time I was just thinking
man because I can't catch up with him
right now
he's going I'm going so fast he's going
faster than me and Greg's in there
that's the whole thing I was thinking
that the whole time and I was I can't
wait to see what Greg says I'm
sorry Greg uh
it was fun now well and when I would
come around a turn and see like a long
straight away and I didn't see you I
began to question
you started looking over this yeah I was
like if they go over the side we're not
finding them today because how are we
going to know where they went over I I I
felt um
I mean
I didn't get close to the edge
I was hugging the I was hugging the
Mountainside
and it was fun
it was fun we may have not actually been
in danger at any point I'm just saying
that to me
I completely understand how fun it is
and like that's the whole point of it
like the simulated or actual risk is
part of the reward right this is what
Daredevil stuff is all about this is why
Red Bull exists as a brand the thing
that's interesting to me as is
illustrated by the the way that you just
described it is that you actually don't
have a perception of the risk like it
doesn't register with you that like oh
I'm doing something very dangerous when
I'm doing it the whole time I'm thinking
this could be a life-changing thing like
I could make a mistake on this and go
right off this thing or come around this
turn and run somebody head-on like in my
the rest of my life is going to be
different but then I'm like but I'm
having more fun than that than that
concerned the fun is outweighing the the
concern
my perception of you is that you there's
no concern the concern is completely
absent I I do think that I am a best
case scenario boy
you're a whale boy I'm a best case
scenario boy
as opposed to a worst case scenario and
uh there's probably people all along the
Spectrum and that's probably so yeah
it's
like it's not it's
you know it's kind of a downer to think
about the worst case scenario well let
me just be clear and I do think that
spectrum of people
I'm on the end of
not of taking a lot of risks doing risky
things I don't constantly think about
the worst case scenario and I'm not like
I'm not an Instagram six I don't think I
don't not do things because I don't
worry about my life it's just when I'm
doing risky things I'm like I want to do
this in a responsible way I was very
confident in my ability that's what
that's what uh that's what Greg Greg
Greg had I wish I could have recorded
the things that Greg said when he got
into the and was slowly coming back to
normal
as he was driving down the mountain uh
he said something about your confidence
uh I think it may have been
um blind confidence I feel like I'm a
good extreme driver
you know I'm sure you are
we we just uh we just drove and drove
back from visiting Lily and it was like
six hour drive and
um you know six hours can turn into
eight or it can turn into five depending
on how you drive
and um Christy doesn't like to drive and
I was like you know what you're sleepy
just go to sleep
and I I kept looking over at her and a
couple times she tried to go to sleep
and every and then I'd look at her again
she'd be wide awake again
and I guess she's learned to say
anything to me I am an I'm an aggressive
driver
um
but I couldn't help but notice that
every time I would switch lanes
um
Chrissy would look in the mirror
Chrissy would always look in the mirror
like the to see it right
and I didn't say anything to her I was
like well you know if if she wants to
she's not relaxed she wants to help she
can help but I mean we got there in
record time we got back in record time I
mean it was kind of your fault I mean
you called us up and you're like hey if
you get back in time I'm I'm I'm slow
roasting up pork butt I'm making some
barbecue I was like um
best case scenario boys got to get back
for that barbecue that's the best case
scenario and boy I I made I made it back
in under five hours
for something it was awesome when your
wife had a great but she wore out that
side mirror just looking and talked to
her about it no there's nothing to be
said
it's nothing to be said so I I believe
in taking risks like I I think that I I
was watching this Tick Tock I just
didn't think I didn't think I was taking
a risk and I think that's your point I
felt like I was in a safe Fun Zone
uh
uh I wasn't gonna go up the mountain
when you go around a blind turn
balls to the wall without slowing down
at all when we're on kind of like almost
a single track thing at that point when
there's other UTV's coming down the hill
like why do you not slow down
because I was going well because I was
really hugging the right but do you
think and I think if anybody's coming
around the curve when you're doing that
are you thinking to yourself
are you pushing it out of your mind that
maybe somebody could be coming around
it's unlikely that it's gonna happen
yeah it's very unlikely and I can react
and they're probably gonna they're not
gonna be
coming around that close to me
unless they're you
yeah unless him right right right yeah
exactly so if it's another you count on
me being one of a kind so if if you are
coming down you're not going to be
hugging the outside of the mountain
you're going to be on the inside coming
down because that's the safe spot
in terms of the slope right
I mean we met one other ATV going up and
I passed yeah and I'm not listen I
didn't slow when you stopped
I probably caught up with you and like
60 to 90 seconds it wasn't a but I'm
just saying that like when I got to a
blind curve I would just I would I
wouldn't just say uh pedals in the
middle I would just take a little bit
off and then when I would then I come
around I'd be like I I link has to not
be letting up at all and then Greg was
like he was puddled in the middle room
every blind card
so I'm just I mean I probably would have
blew it I'm a little bit worried about
you because you do you have a history of
breaking bones I saw a tick tock of a
guy doing something that I would never
do okay he was at the Grand Canyon and
he was like ready and then he like he
like takes a four-step running thing and
then he jumps over the railing and to
land on the other side which from the
angle of the camera you couldn't see
that there was ground on the other side
of the railing
but the thing that he didn't take into
account was that the ground on the other
side of the railing was sloped back
towards some trouble and yeah into the
Grand Canyon so the dude goes over the
rail and then he's like got this smile
in his face like gotcha and then as he
lands
he tumbles tumble tumble tumble
and then the woman
his wife his loved one Whatever who's
videoing this
and then he's like he couldn't have
gotten any closer without just going
over but he saved himself
well he stopped he stopped almost
falling yeah I would never do that that
I mean that is patently stupid
and that's different
yeah because you don't like you don't
like you don't want to go rock climbing
you've never expressed a desire to
discuss skydiving I actually want I want
to skydive
Shepherd really wants to skydive so I'm
probably gonna do that with him at some
point yeah I mean I
I like driving
um I mean I do feel like I'm not like a
total idiot it's just not about being an
idiot that's not what I'm saying I'm
just saying that
I didn't totally disengage my brain when
but when someone else is experiencing it
with you they are perceiving the danger
and then when I bring this up to you
you're like what Greg was having like
Greg was scared that's that was it
seemed like it was a surprise to you and
it wasn't a surprise to me at all as the
person driving behind you I was like
Greg's [__] like [__] in his pants
right now yeah
I did notice there were no high fives
but uh again
to bring it back to the fact that we
have
um
you know all these things that we're
talking about doing that are that are
fun are different levels of danger and
I'm all for it last time we talked about
this then after when we Quantified what
are the most dangerous things we do
that's when I broke my collarbone after
that yeah I'm not comfortable having
this conversation because you're jinxing
it no no I just think that you're
actually willing my injuries well the
the there's the balls to the Wallman so
it's not don't do the things it's just
this like okay there are certain moments
in which pulling back a little bit is
gonna
drastically decrease chances of
something going sideways but I don't
think you should not do it there's you
may have seen there's a genre of tick
tock that usually is from
like a brain doctor
uh and they say things like
10 things that I would not do as a brain
doctor or what I guess that's a
neurologist
um okay
and then they begin to list things and
you know some of it is stuff that I also
wouldn't do but then
some of it's things like well like I
don't I don't know what what I mean if
it was like 10 Things I wouldn't do as a
safety specialist like I don't know why
never ride a motorcycle
oh because of the brain injury yeah
they're just like riding a motorcycle
not worth the risk and I'm like okay
well yeah uh I don't know exactly how
much I agree with that like
my wife doesn't want me to ride a
motorcycle
and so it's I'm just like okay I don't
really want to ride a motorcycle enough
to begin that discussion
but right maybe if it was like okay well
we're gonna rent these dirt bikes and go
through this desert thing on these dirt
bikes and I'd be like okay I'll do that
yeah but I'm gonna ride my motorcycle
across the country on roads with cars on
them that will annihilate me if I run
into them okay maybe that's not a risk I
want to take
but I just did what I found myself
thinking is I don't agree with living
like this
because
I could die by like just some weird
thing falling on me that I have no
control over you know so I'm not gonna
completely try to eliminate risk
I'm just gonna try to be like okay well
I and I think one of the things that I
think with things like white water
rafting and the utving I'm like this is
something that normal people pay for on
a daily basis like every single day
these guys take a group of people of
various athletic inclination out onto
this River to do this thing I'm not Alex
honold trying to like be the first guy
to freak solo right El Capitan you know
so
if I'm doing something that's I'm not
the first one to do it then I think I'm
gonna be okay
that's that's my general and then when
I'm doing it yeah maybe I'll do it in a
way that like takes into account the
risk like the most risky thing that we
did I think was a UTV and because that
was the point in which we weren't in
control rafting the guide could be do we
could be four dead bodies and the guide
would be okay right he doesn't really
need us to paddle it just makes us feel
like we're getting our money's worth
that's my theory at least probably wrong
but well I think with the weight you
have to paddle but you got to do some
paddling but he could probably get so
with white water rafting on the
neurologist list no was UTV
no the only Motorsport was a motorcycle
uh I don't remember the other things
but just the the point being
I'm not gonna repeatedly banging your
head against the line I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna live in such a way oh she was
like
uh I would never let my child play
tackle football before the age of 14.
so it wasn't like I'll never let my kid
play tackle football period it was just
definitely not before the age of 14.
uh which you know if I had kids you
really wanted to play football I'd
probably try to deter it
um
but I think calculate I think calculated
risk is I mean it's these things are fun
for a reason it's the same reason I like
horror movies because I'm like I'm not
going to die I'm not that demon is not
gonna possess me it's gonna possess that
person on the screen
and unless Brian The Exorcist is right
and just going to the movie is a problem
I
the calculated in the like the word
calculated in front of risk is maybe
I'll think about that uh yeah because as
someone who's just watching from the
outside it feels like once you've
committed to the activity
like there was a calculation that led to
the you making a decision to do it and
then once I'm wearing the helmet and
then once you're in the middle of it I'm
wearing the seatbelt calculation
calculating risk at this point May
hinder my funds so I ain't gonna be
thinking about that while I'm out here
we'll just deal with we'll deal with it
if it happens is that an accurate
description of how of what's going on
maybe maybe I think it's it's it's hard
to you know it's like it's it takes work
and it's not fun work to calculate
well I don't think I spend too much time
doing it to me it was just that's how it
feels to me to me that was my perception
the blind turns is it okay what is going
to say what could happen around this
term
what can happen
yeah right you don't want to think that
you want to think I'm going to go around
this turn as fast as I can
yeah I mean I I was looking
good good good
and if you had a bin with harm or Tim or
no you weren't going to be with me
because I already said I wrote it out in
the beginning
um I just did not know that
well it's funny that you like and the
reason I didn't hear it say it the
reason I didn't want to do it is like I
don't want to I don't want to have a
conflict with him on this trip about
that like if I'm in the passenger seat
and I start trying to tell you how to
drive you're gonna get really mad at me
and it's like I'm not gonna do that I'll
let somebody else do it and Greg's not
gonna say anything but Tim well no Greg
Greg said a lot of the same thing
Tim or Greg ten more harm would probably
would have been like slow down man it's
a blind freaking turn
I think he had a great time I think
sorry Greg the thing is is once you live
and you're welcome quite a thrill yeah
once you live through it yeah it's like
well that was a lot of fun yeah yeah
clean out your britches and uh mail me a
check
um
my favorite memory was the most you know
innocuous part just we're gathered
around the uh fire pit the first night
we're catching up it's just not it's
it's nice to like reconnect with these
our college buddies and like
this
we all have our
who we are on to everybody and then
there's like there's you know we our
friends are professionals
you know I feel like they can come they
can hang out with us and they can just
be they can just let loose professionals
yeah or I mean we're not we're all
professionals we're not professionals
but they are what do you mean by that
they they have they have reputable jobs
where where people people trusting
respect them and they they contribute to
society
and we don't well we do but you know
it's not it's not it's in kind of a
kooky entertaining kind of way it's not
in like a it's not professional at all
yeah yeah it's like um I mean they could
all be members of the Chamber of
Commerce you know but then they come out
with us and we're you know it's like hey
look at us we're we're college boys
again
uh but poor Tim
poor Tim could not get from New York
state to to Durango he was his last
flight you just couldn't get on it he
was like well I could come the next day
and I could miss the first night and I
could miss he ended up deciding and we
all agree this is the best decision
he drove from Denver
instead of getting the flight to Durango
he rented a car and he drove
six hours
to meet up with us that night and it was
after a long day of flying and he was
going to be there at like 1 30 a.m and
first of all
I mean we were hedging at the top of
this because earlier I think I'm I mean
I felt kind of bad like I thought maybe
I didn't know if it was my allergies or
if I was coming down with something and
we had a long day of flying and I ain't
got a lot of sleep that week trying to
get ready for the trip and
I was like I think I'll probably be in
bed by the time you show up after
driving six hours but then as we the
four of us were kind of around the fire
outside
and uh we were like let's check in with
Tim
at that point once we checked in with
him and he's driving and we're like how
you doing like you falling asleep he
says well you know it's you know it's
it's tough to stay awake but talking to
you guys is really helping we put him we
put this the phone in a chair in his
chair and we just included him in the
conversation for a few hours until he
got there but he was going when you
drive from Denver to Durango which first
of all I think during the day would have
been a beautiful drive he couldn't see
[__] the whole time but all he knew was
that he was going into mountain passes
and he would be like I'm going into a
mountain and he would just go it would
just go away and then like and then we
would keep talking 15 to 20 minutes
later he'd be like oh Tim's calling I'm
back I'm going to do about it
[Music]
um I that was one of my favorite
memories was was just the fact that like
we were reconnecting and we were kind of
his Lifeline like keep coming to him
we're here for it you can make it and
but it was almost like as long as I
didn't look at the phone at some points
it was like he was already there yeah
you know and then I looked over there
Tim see what he thought about something
and just be like a little phone propped
up it was it was very it was very
strange it's like kind of like I mean as
we continue to get together year after
year with our college buddies well you
know we'll start dying and then I guess
as we've discussed if we keep getting
together as college buddies uh I'm gonna
kill one
I didn't want Greg's blood on your hands
because you would never ever forgive
yourself that would be pretty bad yeah
that's the thing I need to think about
but then we would just have Greg's
personality on a phone device an app
yeah we'll have it on a device and we
can put we'll always put all of our
college buddies
um
in a chair
to be a part of the conversation but it
will be in an AI representation it'll be
just basically the same yeah um so
that's what we're going to do Tim did
eventually show up and we stayed awake
for him and I will say but we were like
bless his heart bless he had a real
tough time getting back he got back like
a day and a half after everyone else
because of flight the same thing going
back
uh we got home that night Tim later he's
like I got home it's like what yeah Tim
took several things for the team
thankfully he did not have to be the
passenger in your UTV as well
um now one of the things that
I really appreciate appreciate about
this group of guys
is first of all you know
very similar life stage we all got
married within a couple of years of one
another all had kids in the same general
like
five to ten year period or so we're all
kind of dealing with
you know anywhere from
the college student to you know middle
school or anything in between
um
everybody
has been married for over 20 years
20 years or so yeah and to all the you
know the women that we all knew back in
the day and uh and it's like
you know I've said this before when we
talk about our background
um being involved in you know campus
Crusade campus ministry
it's like
one of the positives I've I think I've
firmly established what I feel a
negatives are so you know I've talked
about that a lot but one of the
positives about that about being in a
group that uh there was this intentional
Community but also this intentional like
hey get get inside somebody's Soul a
little bit you know as a friend it's not
just about hey what can we do together
let's party it's about how can we do
life together how can we be there for
one another right and so that even
though we're all in different places in
terms of where we've kind of landed
spiritually
that connection
remains and you can you can have a
conversation about anything
and we're all able to kind of talk about
what we're going through in life right
now and then be this like
supportive group for one another
that I don't know I'm not in any other
I I we've been blessed with being a part
of
groups of friends where that type of
vulnerability and encouragement is kind
of part of it it isn't just with those
guys it's kind of been represented in
most or all of the meaningful adult
friendships that we've had with other
guys yeah
uh I have to assume that that's not
super typical
for guys who get together yeah uh it was
so I'm very thankful it was kind of
baked into us as part of our church
experience that I think it's you know
it's a level of connection
you set the bar at a certain place in
terms of like community and connection
that they're still that's still very
important to us
and defines
a a robust
friendship
you know if you can't if you can't
really go there then you're left
thinking well when something goes wrong
in my life
uh is that then are they they're going
to want to be here for me but like
what's that gonna be like you know it's
is then we start talking about these
things and you I mean I think there are
friends that uh you know your friends
can surprise you
in those moments you know
I would hope that everybody would have a
friend that even if they don't get
really deep all the time that they would
be there for them but I do think that
that's kind of like a St that's the
standard that we bring into what makes
the most meaningful of friendships is
that you can talk about anything and uh
exhibit care
and listen and I and I think one of the
really beautiful things about it as well
is that
while we are at different
we landed in different places we have
different World Views
no one is trying to or no one is trying
to change anybody else's mind no no one
is like actively like
we don't feel like we are projects for
these guys and they don't feel like they
are projects for us definitely it's
about the connection right right and so
in so many when you and it's very it's
very hopeful right well but when you
leave like when you leave the church I
mean I mean I know so many people whose
friendships have been so redefined
because one of the things that happens
so often when you leave the church is
that well first of all you're most often
you're kind of just shunned and you're
kind of held up as this example of what
could go wrong and then people try to
find things about your story and your
circumstances to serve as like you know
warnings for other people
but another thing that happens is that
even when the relationships continue
it's very clear like as someone who's
been on the inside who's someone who's
been in the church who's been an
Evangelical Christian who's been like a
very focused on changing people's minds
and sharing the gospel with people
all your relationship it's just like you
know in one sense it's kind of like when
you're involved in a pyramid scheme and
you're all your relationships become
about you getting people to be a part of
your thing right it's like you can't
have a conversation without wanting to
like sell Mary Kay to somebody
well sometimes it becomes like you can't
have a conversation without wanting to
sell Jesus to somebody and like that
makes relationships awkward and it seems
like is this about is this about love
and connection or is this about an
agenda and that isn't what that doesn't
it doesn't I'm not saying we don't have
great philosophical spiritual
conversations
or we challenge one another but it's
done in love and the thing that is kind
of pervades the conversation is
this love and connection and wanted to
like get under the rocks with each other
yeah it's a beautiful thing
yeah I think it it's
it's life-giving to say that uh you love
when somebody loves you unconditionally
it's life-giving yeah I think it's I
think it boils down to that and um
that's why we're going to do it again
and I'm already thinking about what are
we gonna do now we think we're gonna
move on from no more Whitewater water
rafting yep no more of that just because
we feel like we've done it we've done it
like what else can we do maybe not ATV
and apparently
um there was talk I talked about Alaska
I had a lot of fun doing it don't get me
wrong I'm just not going to be a person
Tim can't get a Durango I don't know how
he's going to get to Alaska at the same
time as us and Alaska is a bit of a
problem I didn't bring this up but my
dad's been talking to me about wanting
to go to Alaska not with me but just in
general
so maybe I this is reconnaissance
that'd be funny the challenge is it has
to be a long weekend is about that's
that's the time that we can all kind of
commit to it
and this day this time was one day long
we want some more we're open to hashtag
gearbiscus let us know if uh if you got
any suggestions for
what here's here's what we came up with
as our criteria we want to have a home
base that's more of a you know we like
to luxuriate in an Airbnb private
setting so not like multi-day like trip
on mule back yeah where you're camping
every single we like a we like a good
hot tub we like a good fire pit we and
then everybody needs their own bed
poor Gray got stuff stuck with the twin
bed this time so I guess I owe him twice
um
what were the other requirements sense
of adventure a sense of adventure
still uh
ice oh and also proximity to a cool town
that was something to harm threw in and
I think like okay first of all Durango
nice Durango is doing a lot we love
Durango a lot really well and we shouted
out the uh
Durango hot springs on our I think on my
Instagram story because
um we met
James who's in charge of well first of
all let me just say we don't we don't
like to talk about
getting recognized because it makes it
sound like we're really into getting
recognized
uh but sometimes you show up in a town
sometimes you show up in a town nobody
says anything nobody knows who we are
has no point of reference and then
sometimes you show up into town and it's
like this town they've caught the
mythical virus or something because
everywhere
every single place that we went every
store every restaurant it wouldn't just
be oh there's one employee who's a
mythical Beast it would be like half the
staff is and all these other people and
you know they're like bringing us stuff
and uh then the guy in charge of visit
Durango shows up at the restaurant and
like he's like this is the best
bartender in Colorado and he's gonna do
this special shot for you guys right now
and he's like whatever you what what
else you want a guy you guys want to do
you want to go to the hot springs what
so thanks to James for that hookup uh if
you're in Durango go to those hot
springs yeah that's a cool spot
it's like a bunch of hot tubs we like we
like chill out in a hot tub and watch
live music
and then the kids the family area was
totally separate love that yeah they've
got a good thing going there they got a
good thing going in Durango in general
and lots of hospitality and lots of
adventure but a lot of good food so that
whole that we wanted to have
uh
the home base a sense of adventure like
we want to do and it doesn't have to be
one big thing it could be like well one
day you're gonna do this and the next
day you're going to do this just some
stuff like dude stuff adventure and then
um and then the last thing being that
like cool
town where you can like go have a drink
or get some good food
so and it doesn't have to be Colorado
but Colorado has a lot of that no it
could be anywhere hashtag year biscuits
let us know or leave us a voicemail 1-88
earpod one I caught you off guard there
uh it's time for me to give my wreck
oh man this is a good one if you love
peanut butter like we do and uh if
you're willing to spend twenty dollars
on a jar of peanut butter treat yourself
do it at least once get yourself some
spoon junkie not a sponsor I just love
this stuff
they have different
um
varietals of
peanut butter nut Butters and the one
that I got is called
crack butter
smooth cinnamon date dual peanut butter
now you can get it off the website for
twenty dollars does it have cardamom in
it can you click on the ingredients
because I think that somebody got cares
for me
no I don't think it does I think there
may be another one that has that it was
like and that was the thing that it I
don't remember they're not spice but
yeah there's no there's a lot of options
I like to slice apples and dip it into
the crack butter spoon junkie use a
apple slicer
you gotta get one of those I think I
think I have one that's another wreck
for another day
spoon Junkie
I don't I guess it's a heroin reference
well it is now I mean the name of the
the name of the flavor I like is crack
butter yeah I think they're a little
irreverent
or maybe there's crack in it
food is not well regulated
there's not
goodness
we'll see you next time
hi Rhett and Link I'm a newer ear
biscuits pod listener and viewer and I
just wanted to call to tell you guys the
beautiful visualization I see every time
I hear the title of the podcast ear
biscuits you know when you bust open
like a can of like Pillsbury
biscuits or like croissants
and it doesn't bust open like very far
there's just like a little crack and the
air comes out and pushes the biscuit out
I just imagine that coming out of an ear
was kind of a fart sound
it's kind of a cute little
visualization that I get when I see the
name ear biscuits so thank you for that
I love it bye to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
foreign